we've talked a lot about the Georgia
Senate race the Arizona senate race
2024 presidential contest we haven't
talked a ton about the New Hampshire
Miss America contests okay and we
haven't talked in particular about Brian
noyan
Brian noyan who is the first man to uh
win the Miss greater Derry 2023
competition
your new Miss greater Dairy
is Brian neum when you see him in his
dress
and all the poor little cute blonde
girls or they have to pretend to be
happy behind him and then he who is a
for those of you who are not watching
right now for those of you who are only
listening this man is
I don't want to be mean to the guy
he
there's a lot of pretty little blonde
girls around him who look like you know
young blonde girls and then there's this
more corpulent guy a little it just
looks more like a man
and he's bigger and he's just bigger
okay and he is up
he wouldn't have gotten my vote for Miss
greater Dairy I'm not on the Electoral
commission for this contest but
it's
absurd
how did he win
even if he were a woman
it would not make sense for for him to
win this beauty contest okay he probably
has many other virtues and talents but
this would not he should not win so why
why they have to do it they have to do
it because
the left we know hates truth and the
left we know hates goodness and the left
also hates that third transcendental
hates Beauty that's why the leftists all
over the world are throwing soup on on
famous beautiful paintings
that's why they attack beautiful
buildings in beautiful architecture and
they try to burn these things to the
ground the left hates Beauty and so the
left has to redefine truth as falsehood
and goodness is evil and Beauty as
grotesquery
and that is what
they're doing
this this is why now when you see
Billboards for clothing I used to be
you'd go in magazines and you'd see on
billboards for clothing companies you'd
have these beautiful models you know
Christy Brinkley right Heidi Klum oh my
God Tyra Banks you know these really
beautiful people
now you don't see those people on the
Billboards and in the magazines you see
you see big
ugly mutilated people who who make
themselves look uglier than they
otherwise would who contort themselves
and try and and that's they call it
positivity it's not positivity
it's a an inversion of Standards to
reorder all of society that's what
they're really after
it's part of the exact same attack on
truth and goodness that we see
everywhere they have to do it
and the and the the saddest part of it
the most sort of stalin-esque
totalitarian part of it is those poor
little girls in the background who one
of whom should have won the contest they
have to applaud they and they have to
smile and they have to say oh this is so
great that this big dude won the girls
beauty pageant just like all those girls
on the swim team at UPenn have to smile
and applaud when that big dude will
Thomas who calls himself Leah
takes all of their trophies they have to
do it because if they do not
affirm this absurd dominant regime they
will be exiled they will be ostracized
they'll be called awful phobic terrible
people so they have to do it too and
you're supposed to do it too and I'm
supposed to do it too
and I don't and then they take some of
my shows off YouTube and you know don't
invite me to the nice fancy parties and
things like that but
it's a it's a total kind of ideology
it's everywhere it's not just Joe Biden
and that fellow Richard Levine the
assistant Health secretary it's not just
them from the official government posts
who are pushing the trans ideology it's
everywhere it's all the way down to the
little teen beauty pageant in this
greater Dairy
2023. right now head on over to
establishtitles.com Knowles established
titles is your opportunity to earn the
title of Lord or lady and gain the
respect you deserve all you need is a
one square foot plot of land in Scotland
okay I had this problem where I thought
I'm just not getting the respect that is
due to me okay people when they come up
to me they'd say hey Michael
hey Mr note mister
I want to be referred to as a lard or a
lord okay there is this uh wonderful
Scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lards and ladies well in
your title pack you will be bestowed
with at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston Scotland plus an official
certificate with a Crest your
certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there are a couple
packs because you don't want to let your
wife you know just be some strumpet
you're a Lord and then she's just some
chick on the street so you want her to
be a lady as well established titles
told me that the first 200 people to
purchase a title pack using my exclusive
link will receive a plot within walking
distance of mine depending on how many
of you want to become a lord or a lady
we can begin to build our own kingdom
established titles is actually running a
massive sale right now and if you use
code Knowles at checkout you will get an
additional 10 off go to established
titles.com Knowles to get your gifts now
and help support the channel
The Establishment has bought into
transgenderism even though the people
broadly don't like it even though the
Republicans who did very very well in
the midterms and in recent years
have done so running against
transgenderism and thinking of Ron
DeSantis especially in Florida biggest
winner of the night
during the midterms I'm thinking of
Glenn yonkin in Virginia I'm thinking of
an issue that has brought a lot of
people over from the Democrat side to
the Republican side
The Establishment still pushes it
including the supposedly right-wing
media channels
not all of them but the ones
that have most accommodated themselves
to the elite kind of media apparatus
they go along with it you know I'm not
surprised when NBC and ABC and CNN and
all the New York Times Washington Post
I'm not surprised when they buy into the
absolutely absurd idea that a man is a
woman and that a man who dyes his hair a
crazy color and mutilates his body is
you know puts lipstick on you know is is
totally normal and and brave and
stunning and so so brilliant and you
know should be affirmed in that delusion
I'm not surprised by that
but even I with my low expectations was
surprised I shouldn't be anymore but I
was surprised to see this piece from Fox
News
Fox News tweets out yesterday
breaking barriers lay thinky attributed
her Victory to the rise of queer
political power
I said oh lay Finke who's life thinking
and I look at the picture and it's this
you know poor
caricature of a troubled man who has
pink dyed hair in a woman's haircut and
is wearing a kind of turquoise
woman's top and wearing lipstick and
it's just
ridiculous the man should be in an
insane asylum not not in any sort of
political office and then I read the
headline and I thought is Fox News kind
of mocking this absurdity is Fox News is
this a sort of tongue-in-cheek
but Fox used the pronoun
Fox News is referring to a dude who is
very obviously a dude as her
unironically I think I've got the
article here
Minnesota elect's first transgender
State lawmaker
even though even to use the phrase
transgender seriously
is is just to buy the premise of of the
left which is absurd the idea that there
is such a thing as transgenderism there
is not there is no ontological category
of you know trans women or trans men it
doesn't exist
there are men who wrongly Express their
sexual nature
and and women who wrongly Express their
sexual nature but there's no such thing
as transgender
as a as an actual category of being
Minnesota voters have elected the
state's first transgender lawmaker into
office
finke's opponent lost received you know
just 18.5 percent of the vote
when Finke is sworn into office in
January she will replace Alice Houseman
who was first elected to office in 1989.
oh my goodness gracious she her she
many stories will be written about
Minnesota's elections she said in a
tweet quoting the victory fund one
undeniable story is the rise of queer
political power yeah that's true we do
have very queer powers in this country
the principalities and powers of this
world have long been a bit queer and
there are now very explicitly queer
including at Fox News I guess
what is that about guys come on you're
come on you're you're supposed to be the
right wing cable channel you know and if
if even the the supposedly right wing
can even center-right conservative cable
channel
is embracing the most insanely radical
leftist idea
possibly in American history
you know who needs Democrats with with
right Wingers like this who needs
leftists
absolutely
pathetic
it's misinformation is what it is to
call that man a woman is misinformation
Elon is censor this tweet it's it's
misinformation
where you're not allowed to mention that
Covenant probably came from a Chinese
laboratory or that the vaccine isn't all
that effective at stopping infection and
transmission of covid that's that's
horrible misinformation but you can call
this obvious dude a chick and that's
that's
true information I don't think so I
don't think so we've got a very
important conservative lawyer coming on
to help us discuss that that would of
course be
Jenna Ellis the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]